[MUSIC PLAYING]
CURTIS SITTENFELD: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Sanders.
And thank you all for coming.
I don't-- you probably--
I know that other
writers come here.
And maybe they all
say the same thing.
I've actually watched a
few of these talks online.
But I often visit
bookstores or libraries
and talk about my books.
But it's very unusual
to have a daytime event
and to be essentially
in an office.
And I think even if
someone's like, it's
7:00 PM on a Tuesday night.
And are they going to-- do
they have the motivation
to go to a bookstore?
And I think sometimes
it can be a struggle
to get out of the house.
But I can only imagine if
you're actually in your office,
on some kind of
deadline or something.
So I appreciate it.
I also have one Google story.
Which is-- this is
about how I could
have changed the fate of
either Google or human history.
I graduated from
Stanford in 1997.
And like all intelligent
young people at the time,
I thought that it would be a
very lucrative and stable thing
to go into the field of
writing, as one you did then.
And I had no idea.
I was an English major.
So I didn't--
I feel like I sort of
heard of these search
engines that were popping up.
Yahoo had formed on campus.
And Google had formed on campus.
Although I'm not even
sure of the exact timing
and chronology.
But I worked for the "Stanford
Daily," the student newspaper.
And I was primarily--
I was an editor and writer
for the Feature section
and the Arts and
Entertainment section.
But one evening, in the
spring of 1997, in a pinch,
they needed a copy editor.
So I was reading--
it was almost like--
I can't remember
if it was before
or after the section editor
had read the article.
And I think-- I need
to actually find this.
Because it would be
interesting to go back.
But an undergrad-- I think I
was a senior-- an undergrad had
turned in an article.
And I believe it was
describing this--
I think that officially--
I looked this up today-- that
the domain name for Google
was registered in
September 1997.
So that hadn't
even happened yet.
So I'm not even sure
what it was being called.
But there was this article
where it kept saying this search
engine, this search engine.
And I remember
saying to the writer,
"I think search engine
is a really weird term.
And I think we should
call it something else."
And the writer had
to say, "Curtis,
that's what it's called.
That is the--" And I do wonder--
I still-- there's
a part of me that
feels like it was
early enough that if I
had been a little
more aggressive,
I could've changed the name.
And I was trying to think of--
on the plane coming here today--
I was like, well, what
should I have changed it to?
And I don't--
there was nothing--
I was sort of torn between
democracy encourager or Kim
Kardashian butt depictor.
There's the good and bad
sides of the search engine.
I think that they did
make the right choice.
And it was good that I was
not the decider in that case.
So what I'm going to do today
is talk a little bit about how
I came to write a book of short
stories, which I believe--
I don't usually say
this at events--
I believe there are free
copies in the first few rows
if you want one.
And then I'll read a tiny
bit to give you a flavor.
And then, if you
have questions, I
would be happy to
try to answer them.
Including, I assume
that there are probably
several people in here
who are writing novels
and/or story collections
of their own.
So we can talk about that.
So one thing that I'm
curious-- because I
imagine that those
of you who are here
have different specific jobs.
But raise your hand
if you have heard
that there's a short story
renaissance going on right now.
All right.
Now all of you have.
Because people-- when I--
this book came out
just a week ago.
And I've been doing interviews.
And a lot of
journalists are saying,
why are short stories
having a moment?
And I can't tell who thinks
they're having a moment and who
doesn't.
I mean, that's
sort of subjective.
But I think that right now--
it is a couple of
things going on.
There are few people
who usually write novels
who have story collections out.
I'm one of those people.
I've written five novels,
and this is my first story
collection.
Someone else is Lionel
Shriver has a story collection
out right now.
Someone named Joseph O'Neill has
a story collection coming out.
And there's definitely
lots of buzzy books.
There's someone named--
I think you say his name
Jamel Brinkley, who had a
book just come out yesterday
that's this super
buzzy story collection.
And then there's also-- there
was a story in "The New Yorker"
in December called Cat Person.
OK.
One more.
I won't keep doing this.
But raise your hand if you
have heard of Cat Person.
That's so interesting.
So this story got
a ton of attention.
And I loved it.
It's a wonderful story but
it definitely transcended--
I have three siblings.
None of them are writers.
And they all said to me, we
need to talk about Cat Person.
I don't even think they read
a story in "The New Yorker"
from one year to the next.
And they all-- we had to process
our emotions about Cat Person
all together.
It kind of-- it's not
about the MeToo movement.
But it kind of touches
on issues from that.
So it was very timely.
And it had this very striking
photo accompanying it.
But in terms of whether there is
a short story renaissance going
on, I feel like
great if there is.
I think that people are
always writing short stories.
And sometimes the larger
culture pays attention.
And sometimes it doesn't.
But people who love
short stories I think
would maybe push back
against this idea.
But then, at the
same time, it's true.
Undeniably, we all have slightly
shrinking attention spans.
Maybe some of you are partially
responsible for that, which
could be a point of pride.
Congratulations.
And on the one hand,
I think that if you
can find the right novel
and absorb yourself into it,
it's a wonderful
experience, especially now.
But at the same time,
if you are going to bed.
And maybe you want to do
something other than look
at a screen in those
last 20 minutes,
reading a short story can be
this is a wonderful experience.
And it can feel
maybe more manageable
than starting a 700-page
novel or a 400-page novel
or something like that.
So the way that I came to
write this story collection
is basically I was one of those
people who from childhood,
from the time that I knew
how to read and write,
I loved reading stories.
I loved writing stories.
I ended up going
to graduate school
at the Iowa Writer's Workshop.
I basically jumped
over 20 years.
And I think a lot of times
people think of-- fiction
writers think of stories as
sort of their apprenticeship
while they're learning
to write a novel,
or moving toward
writing a novel.
And in some ways, that
was what happened to me,
in the sense that my first
book came out in 2005.
And at that point, I was
offered additional contracts
for novels, which I was--
I love novels.
I was really excited.
But I got away from
writing stories.
And I think that they're not
really an apprenticeship.
They are their own
beautiful form.
But I personally got
on this other path.
And so I wrote--
after my first one--
I wrote four more novels.
There's maybe a
period of 12 years
where I was writing novels.
And there would
be some situation.
Or I might think of, that could
be a first line for a story.
But during those
years, I was busy.
I had two children.
I wrote more novels.
I was always on deadline.
And so I didn't really do it.
And then, in the
spring of 2016, I
had just had a novel come out.
I had been going around.
I live in St. Louis, Missouri.
But I had been going
around to different events
in different cities, which was
churning me up a little bit.
The normal life of a writer,
at least for me, is very quiet.
And I'm mostly at
home by myself.
And it's sort of the opposite
of traveling and interacting
with other humans.
And so I thought to re-immerse
myself in writing and in being
more inwardly focused, instead
of writing another novel--
either going back to a novel
that was in progress that was
a huge mess, so it
was off-putting,
or starting a new novel, which
was very daunting in its own
way--
I thought, I'm going
to write a short story.
And I had in the last
12 years, a couple times
I had been commissioned
by editors.
Including most recently
an editor at "Esquire"
had reached out to
me and said, "We
want you to write a story from
the perspective of Hillary
Clinton on the eve of
her official presidential
nomination at the
Democratic Convention."
So again, this is in early 2016.
I write the story.
So I had a little hesitation
because I said, "Well,
what if it ends up that
she's not the frontrunner
and Bernie Sanders is?"
So there was some
confusion and doubt
I had about the 2016 election.
But it was completely
the wrong confusion.
So I wrote that story.
Again, came out--
it came out even
before the actual
convention had occurred.
And something that's
very interesting to me,
as a writer and a reader, is--
I was in London last week.
And I did an event where
they asked me to read
a story in its entirety.
And of course, with almost--
maybe like four words in it are
different now--
it's a completely
different story
than it was when I wrote it.
And I feel that as a person,
that if I read a story--
my favorite writer is the
Canadian writer Alice Munro.
And if I read a story
of hers when I was 20,
and I now read it, I might
have loved it back then.
But now that I've gotten
married or I've had children
or I've just gotten
two decades older,
I can see it in a
totally different light.
So it is an interesting thing.
And a couple of these
stories, they're
not exactly about Donald Trump.
But they-- that's the backdrop
for some of the characters
interacting.
The book starts with a
man and woman interacting
in the summer of 2015.
And it's a female professor and
a male airport shuttle driver.
And he's a Trump
supporter sharing
his unsolicited political views.
And she's sort of
impatiently listening.
But then she loses
her driver's license
and must contact him later.
So they end up having
a longer conversation.
And that's the story that opens.
And then, the story
that closes the book
is, there's two people who went
to boarding school together
who--
25 years ago-- who were in--
a man and woman are, at
the time a boy and girl,
who ran a student government
election against each other.
And the results
were sort of murky.
And after the 2016 election,
the woman reaches out to the man
and says, "I'm going to be
in Chicago," where he lives.
"Would you like to have dinner?"
And he thinks she's coming
to kind of reconcile
this thing that happened.
And she actually has a
completely different agenda
that I'll let you discover
for yourself if you'd
like to read the story.
But it's again that issue of
an experience in life can--
the experience can stay the
same or be preserved in amber.
But because we change,
our perspective on it
changes, which is a very,
very interesting thing for me
to think about.
I feel like, again, in so far
as we're having a short story
renaissance, I
think that usually I
don't think it's fiction's
job to capture the zeitgeist
or to be timely or make
political commentary.
That's more like opinion
pieces do that, or essays.
But the reality is that a story
can be written in a few weeks.
I mean, there are
some people who
are superhuman who can actually
write a novel in a few weeks.
I'm not one of them.
So a story can, I think,
contain the current moment
more than a novel can.
And it can also contain
a certain energy.
Where a story
hinges on a moment,
instead of covering a much
longer section of time.
OK.
I'm just going to--
I'm going to give
you a little flavor.
So this is the story--
the story itself.
It's the second
story in the book.
And it's called The World
has Many Butterflies.
It actually gives
the book its title,
even though no story
in the whole book
has that exact title.
But it becomes, I think,
pretty self-explanatory.
And also, if you
are holding a book,
there's a few sentences
that I don't read.
Because I've realized
the hard way,
they're too awkward to say those
sentences into a microphone.
But you can-- so if you
think, did she skip them?
Yes, I did skip them.
On purpose.
"Julie and Graham had known
each other for eight years
before they ever played
I'll Think It, You Say It.
Then they played I'll Think
It, You Say It for a year
before Julie decided--
decided, realized, idiotically
fabricated the belief
that-- she was in
love with Graham.
Graham worked at the same
investment banking firm
in Houston as Julie's husband.
Also, their respective
kids all attended
the same private school, which
meant Julie and Keith saw
Graham and his wife
Gail regularly,
in a way that, for
almost a decade
had barely registered
with Julie.
They showed up at the same
soccer games and school
fundraisers and Christmas
parties and dinner parties.
They greeted one another
in a friendly fashion.
And, in retrospect, Julie
went over it repeatedly,
that innocent earlier era
before she became obsessed.
She thought of Graham as
slightly more appealing
than most men, but neither
fascinating nor smolderingly
handsome.
Even later, Julie
considered Graham and Keith
comparably attractive,
if your thing was preppy
middle-aged men, which
hers apparently was.
It was Brett and Tracy
Hutchinson's 20th anniversary
party at River Oaks
Country Club that Graham
appeared beside Julie, and
said for the first time,
"I'll think it.
You say it."
Julie was standing
alone momentarily,
because the
babysitter had texted
to ask if her youngest child
was allowed to go to sleep
with the light on in his room.
Graham nodded his head once
toward an unofficial receiving
line that had formed
around the party's hosts.
"Well, for starters,"
Julie said,
"I'm surprised they decided
to throw this party.
Because I was always
under the impression
Brett and Tracy kind
of hate each other."
She glanced at
Graham before adding,
"I assume they're celebrating,
what, a total of three
happy years together?"
Graham raised his eyebrows.
"I'd have estimated one.
But sure, let's round up."
"And even though
they're both tedious,
they're tedious in such a
distinctive ways," Julie said.
"With him, it's like
all roads eventually
lead to a disquisition on
the pleasures of hunting
white-tailed deer.
But apart from
being bloodthirsty,
he's really gentle and
has such good manners.
Whereas with her, all roads
lead to her gifted children.
And she's so
aggressive and braggy.
Literally, she's
probably told me
12 times that Mr. Vaughn said
Fritz is the most talented math
student he's ever had."
Julie took a sip
of her champagne
before adding, "To be fair,
Tracy does look great tonight.
Her Spanx must be killing her.
But she looks great."
"What are Spanx?"
Graham asked.
"Seriously?
They're shapewear."
Julie made air quotes.
"They smooth out your
womanly lumps and bumps."
"And here I thought
womanly lumps and bumps
were one of life's great
gifts," Graham said.
"Depending on the location."
When Julie and Graham's eyes
met, she said, "Who else?"
So that's the game they play.
And obviously,
the game is called
I'll Think It, You Say It.
And a friend of mine--
a writer friend named
Emily-- read that story.
And she said, "Well
the interesting thing
is, in some ways Curtis,
that's what you're writing.
That you're writing says the
thing that people are thinking.
But probably wouldn't
express, because it's
too rude and uncomfortable."
Which of course I took
as a huge compliment.
And so I thought, you've
given me my title.
Like I don't-- and to be fair,
she is one of the three people
to whom the entire story
collection is dedicated.
And actually another
one is a friend of mine.
And the rest of the
story is fictitious.
But this friend of
mine was at a party.
And my friend is very witty.
And a man came up to her
and said, "I'll think it.
You say it."
And they did not proceed to
get emotionally entangled
with each other, as the
characters did in the story.
But I thought, oh my God.
That's such a juicy
premise for a story.
And I will say, I asked
my friend permission
if I could steal
it from her life.
And when she said yes, I also
dedicated the book to her too.
All right.
If you have any questions about
writing, Stanford in 1997,
agents, creativity, Cat Person.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
You just mentioned that you
showed your friend that story.
And you went to the
Iowa Writer's Workshop.
Do you feel like you
still really work
in a workshop format, where
either chapter by chapter
or story by story,
you really look
for that feedback from
people that you trust?
CURTIS SITTENFELD: Yes.
The short answer
is definitely yes.
So I don't know if you
all are familiar with MFA
programs in Creative Writing.
But essentially the
way that they work is--
it's funny.
Because unlike say,
getting a law degree
or getting a degree in other,
more scientific fields,
there's no guarantee that
you're qualified for really
anything upon graduating.
But during the
time you're there,
you've received
this gift of time.
And you've also, under
ideal circumstances,
you've found other people
who can read your work
and give you hopefully
honest and helpful feedback.
And the beautiful thing is
to find a kindred spirit
in writing sensibility.
Your writing doesn't really
have to be very similar.
You just have to-- it's almost
like you and the other person--
and ideally, it's
a two-way street--
are both trying to help each
other make your writing be
the best version of
what it is, instead
of trying to change
each other's writing
and making it conform more
to your own personal taste.
And so the format
of a workshop is
you turn in a story--
like say, a 20-page story.
And I'm trying to remember.
I think we used to turn
them in on a Thursday.
And then, in the olden
days of the late '90s,
they would get Xeroxed,
put on a shelf,
people would pick them up.
And then on Tuesday,
you'd be in a class
sitting around a square
or rectangular table.
And let's say you
had eight classmates.
They would all-- you
would sit there, silently.
It's considered a violation
of protocol to speak.
Let alone to try to
defend your story.
And these other eight people
would discuss your story
for maybe 40 or 45 minutes.
And then, they
would turn to you,
or the professor
would turn to you
and say, "Do you
have any questions?"
And probably, in minute
14, you had a lot to say.
And then, by minute 40,
you had been crushed.
And you just want to
go get under a blanket.
And then so you say, "No.
Thank you so much for
all your feedback."
And then you probably ignore
what five of the people say.
And maybe you feel sad and
bitter for a few weeks.
And then you realize
that the other three
people had incredibly
wise, insightful feedback.
And you change your story.
And it becomes much better.
And that's what it
is to be a writer.
And so, yes.
I feel like I'm kind
of proud, or too
proud to show my writing when
it's in a super messy state.
Some people might give
you an 80-page manuscript.
They might give it to a friend.
And one thing will be like,
this scene will be here.
And I feel like,
write the scene.
Because it doesn't-- you
can't evaluate something based
on an idea.
It has to be the execution.
So I'll show a first
draft to my inner circle.
And there are some people--
I will say occasionally
I'll think,
I need a straight
man to read this.
Because there are two
straight male protagonists.
And there aren't that many
straight men in my life,
besides the one I'm married to.
So I feel like sometimes
I do have to purposely--
or I one time wrote a novel
that was about a woman born
in the '40s in Wisconsin.
And so I did have several women
born in the '40s in Wisconsin
read a rough draft of the novel.
And they could say, "Well,
we didn't grow soybeans back
in the '50s or whatever.
So I try to foolproof
it like that.
But for me, it's very
important to get feedback.
Other questions?
Comments?
AUDIENCE: Recently rereading
George Orwell's letters
and essays and whatnot.
And he points
out-- this probably
in the '30s or
something like that.
But he was talking to
people who didn't really
like short stories
because the effort of--
the effort of getting into
new characters and whatnot.
You have to do this
every dozen pages.
As opposed to investing
once in a book.
And I suppose the alternative
is some sort of hybrid form,
like an "Olive Kittridge," which
is a novel in story format.
Did you try to link stories?
Or are they all
really independent?
CURTIS SITTENFELD: So
the stories in my book
are independent.
There's also I guess
the novella, which could
be some kind of a compromise.
But I feel as if my stories
are not literally linked.
But they are
thematically linked.
And that was almost a
conscious decision I made.
Where I one time interviewed
a writer, Antonya Nelson, who
primarily wrote short stories.
This was years ago,
at least 15 years ago.
And she said she had
had a professor--
a writing professor--
who said, "You
don't have to purposely
reveal your obsessions.
They will reveal themselves."
And I think that's true.
When I was arranging
the stories,
it was almost like a mixtape.
For those who remember mixtapes.
Where I thought, these
stories echo each other.
And so I do want them
next to each other.
Or these stories
echo each other.
And I don't want them
next to each other.
And some of the
themes that arose
were the passage of
time and the hold
that high school can have
on you and your identity.
And then another
theme was marriage.
theme was a woman
who semi-irrationally
hates another woman
with whom she interacts who
she doesn't know that well.
There's also fame and social
media and public identity.
And so I did think--
sometimes, there will
be a story collection,
and it's almost
like-- and I feel
like people should do-- writers
should do whatever they want.
But it seems like someone
will be almost showing
their range as a writer for the
sake of showing their range.
And it's, this story
is set 200 years ago.
And this is science fiction.
And this is--
And I think that's one approach.
And I went in the
opposite direction.
Where I don't think if you
read any one of these stories,
I don't think you would be
surprised if someone said,
"This other story is
by the same author."
They have fixed perspective
or consistent perspective.
But you're right.
The thing that you're
saying-- there is-- the truth
is that I think a lot
of people in publishing,
who tend to be
passionate readers,
they themselves love stories
and love story collections.
But story collections do tend
to sell a lot less than novels.
And I think it's
often for the reason
that you're saying, where
somebody feels like, I just
got acquainted with who's who.
And I got invested.
And now it's over.
But at the same
time, I think there's
a trade-off to everything.
And there can be a
excitement or energy.
The truth is, I
think most novels--
if a novel's 300 pages, there's
probably 15 pages here or there
that could have been cut.
Could have stayed in.
Who cares?
But in a novel,
there shouldn't be--
sorry, in a story,
there should not
be 15 pages that are take them
or leave them, either way.
Everything should
feel more central.
AUDIENCE: One more
related question.
I read the British
magazine "Granta,"
which has a lot of stories,
shorter form stuff.
But then, when I read
the notes at the back,
I realize that, or I see
that a lot of those quote
unquote stories are
actually chapters from--
CURTIS SITTENFELD: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: -- book in progress.
And so they seem
pretty stand alone.
So do you think of
novels that way?
That you can extract chapters?
Are they made out of
the independent pieces?
CURTIS SITTENFELD: Sometimes.
It probably depends
on the novel.
And it might depend on how
motivated the editor, who's
doing the extracting--
the magazine editor-- is.
I'll tell you the truth
is-- so for about 20 years,
I submitted, off and
on, I submitted stories
to "The New Yorker."
And "The New Yorker" would
always say, "No, thank you.
And then, in summer of 2016,
they finally said, "Yes.
OK.
We'll take--"
And it's the first story
in here, Gender Studies.
And I think that acceptance
encouraged me, actually,
to keep writing stories.
But during the time
that "The New Yorker"--
during that two decades thing
while "The New Yorker" was not
accepting work from me--
my agents had submitted my
novels in their entirety,
to say, "Would you
like an excerpt?"
And they would say, "No thanks.
But best of luck."
So I think that there are--
I remember the novel that just
won the Pulitzer Prize, "Less"
by Andrew Sean Greer,
that was excerpted.
There was a short story
in "The New Yorker."
And actually another one,
"The Idiot" by a woman.
I need to learn to
pronounce her name.
It's E-L-I-F. Elif?
Batuman.
Do any of you know
how to pronounce that?
Anyway, she wrote a
book called "The Idiot."
It's great.
That too was excerpted
in "The New Yorker."
And sometimes, I read something.
And I think it is a short story.
And then, I find
out it's a novel.
And sometimes I can tell
that it's a novel that's--
everything is its own animal
and structured differently.
AUDIENCE: So you'd probably
enjoy "The New Yorker"
book of rejected cartoons.
CURTIS SITTENFELD: Ha.
Ha.
I am surprised to say I don't
own it and haven't seen it.
But I feel like I
would feel a sense of--
AUDIENCE: The cartoons
seem just as good
as the accepted ones to me.
CURTIS SITTENFELD: --kinship.
There's a lot of--
if you-- I'm sure some of
you read "The New Yorker",
that back page.
Sometimes I think, all three
of these are equally hilarious.
They all deserve to be--
AUDIENCE: So I read
"Prep" when it came out,
as I know a couple other
people did as well here.
And I've always wanted to know--
I went to a boarding
school in Massachusetts.
Has it ever been
revealed what the school
you created the fictitiional
school after was?
CURTIS SITTENFELD: So
my first novel "Prep"
was set in Massachusetts
boarding school.
Which of course
is a funny thing.
Again, I live in St. Louis.
And so I would pretty
much never be asked
that question in St. Louis.
But now I'm back in the
bosom of the prep school.
So in real life,
I went to Groton.
I graduated in 1993.
And I would say that "Prep"--
I would say that the novel
is not autobiographical.
But the school, which is called
Ault, is Groton in the sense
that-- the biggest
parallels are the campus
is the Groton campus.
So the buildings and the layout.
And some of the
schedule or rituals.
Or there's something
called Surprise Holiday.
There's something called
Surprise Holiday at Groton.
So yeah, I feel like it's not--
the things that are described--
and that's, in a way,
to be a writer, I think,
I feel at times like--
to be a fiction writer that
I'm a bird building a nest.
And that I'll take things
from wherever I need them.
This thing that my sister
told me 12 years ago.
And this thing that's
from my imagination.
And this thing that I observed.
And just mix together
somewhat shamelessly.
Which I think can be unsettling
or confusing to people
who are familiar with any
part of what is realistic.
And so even for my family
to read my fiction--
I think it's safe to say,
my family is supportive.
And they're not
my ideal audience.
Because they will--
I wrote a novel
called "Sisterland."
And at one point,
there's a teenage girl
who rides a Greyhound bus
across several states.
And a man sitting next to her
asks if she'll pierce his ear.
And it's this total
throw away line.
And my older sister said,
"Yeah, nice reference
to when that guy asked me
to pierce his ear in 1989."
And I thought to myself, oh,
I did steal that from you?
It wasn't even
conscious or deliberate
or it didn't have-- it wasn't
like I was trying to send
my sister a secret message.
It was more like, oh,
what's a colorful thing that
could happen when one
is riding Greyhound?
So it's not-- I do feel
like I did certainly
borrow from Groton, and it
would be ridiculous to pretend
otherwise.
But it's not as if I feel like
I have some clear view of what
I think of Groton.
And this is what I
want to say about it.
Because if I did, I
would write an essay.
I also will say, there
is, in this collection,
there are two stories that
are boarding school adjacent.
Or they're almost like
cousins of "Prep," or sequels
to "Prep" sort of.
And there's a part of me
that thinks, Curtis, you
graduated 25 years ago.
Get over it.
And then there's another
part of me that thinks, oh,
but it's so juicy
and interesting.
Just go with your obsession.
So you all can decide
if they feel "Prep"-ish,
those of you who have read it.
AUDIENCE: So I was wondering if
since we are in a short story
renaissance, do
you feel that that
is something that's being
echoed by the publishing houses
as well?
Or is it still a tough sell to
get publishing houses to invest
in a short story [INAUDIBLE]?
CURTIS SITTENFELD: That
is a great question
that I don't think I
know the answer to.
And I also don't know--
it probably-- if there is
a short story renaissance--
let's say there are--
I'm sure the number
is much higher,
but let's say there are 10
story collections coming out
from two months ago to
four months from now.
It probably-- I'm sure there are
probably 500 story collections
coming out during that time.
It probably depends honestly
in part how they sell.
Because it's like think about--
I'm sure that some of
you read "Gone Girl."
In some ways,
"Gone Girl" I think
prompted the publication
of some similar books.
If something is
successful, people
will think-- people
in publishing
will think maybe there's
more of an appetite for this.
I'm not at all
disdainful about--
publishing is a business.
It's not for hobbyists.
Again, it tends to be populated
by people who love to read.
But it'll be
interesting to see that.
I mean, I think, also
again, book clubs
don't pick story
collections as much to read.
And book clubs can be really
influential in determining--
we can meet back
here in six months
and assess the situation.
AUDIENCE: So did you write
them all sequentially?
Did you have a
plan going into it?
I just read "Fresh Complaint"
by Jeffrey Eugenides.
That seemed like it was a
hodgepodge of the last 20
years.
It was good, but--
CURTIS SITTENFELD: Yeah.
Yeah.
So what I did,
actually, was after I
had assembled enough stories
that I felt like, OK, this
could be a collection--
first I had to check
in with my publisher.
Because I wasn't completely
certain that they would
want to publish a collection.
And I was delighted
when they did.
And then, it was actually
a high priority for them.
And it's certainly-- I wish
that my professional problem was
like, every time I submit a
story to "The New Yorker,"
it gets in.
That's not my
professional problem.
But my publisher did say, "Stop
submitting to "The New Yorker."
If we're going to
publish this collection,
we do not want any
more of the stories
to already have been
published and be accessible.
And we want people to feel
like they're getting something
new and fresh in the book.
And so half the stories have
never been published anywhere.
And half the stories have been.
So three of them were
published in the past.
And then seven of
them I wrote in this--
there was this wave of my
own personal short story
renaissance.
When I knew that I was
going to have a collection,
I actually printed them all out.
And put them on the
floor of my office.
And physically was moving
them around and thinking
in terms of time in the--
what time period, what
year is it in the story?
What themes does it have?
How old is the protagonist?
How will these echo each other?
And the story that I mentioned
that I wrote for "Esquire"
about Hillary Clinton,
at one point that
was the starting story.
But it was really written
almost like, here I
am in the Wells Fargo about to
give this speech or whatever.
It was really a first person
thing, from her point of view.
And so it felt different.
And I think my
publisher felt like it
felt a little confusing.
Because as it happens,
I'm writing a novel
from the perspective of Hillary
Clinton to my own surprise.
The premise of it is if
Hillary Clinton-- in real life,
obviously, she went
to Yale Law School.
She met and fell in
love with Bill Clinton.
Well, she was Hillary
Rodham at the time.
And then, also in real life, he
proposed to her multiple times
before she accepted.
And so my premise is,
what if all that happened?
But she ultimately
declined his proposals
and went on her own way.
And because if you
are somebody who
follows writerly gossip,
which I assume you all do,
that news is out there
that I'm writing this.
And so I think they thought
that, this will be confusing.
And then that kind of
redistributed things.
But I don't-- it's hard to say.
It's almost like, I think,
naming a child or something.
Where sometimes, maybe seven
years later, you'll think,
should I have given my
child a different name?
And it's like, should these be
a completely different order?
Maybe they should.
Maybe they shouldn't.
But it is what it is
at a certain point.
AUDIENCE: I had a
question actually.
So I found it really
interesting that about half
the short stories
in the collection
were told in the third
person and about half
were in the first person.
And I was interested
in your thought process
about when you choose to
write from a first person
perspective versus a
third person perspective.
If that's something that you're
very consciously thinking
about when you start
writing, or if it just
evolves more naturally?
CURTIS SITTENFELD: I think it's
much more intuitive, actually.
And I think that very rarely I
have changed it, started in one
direction and gone in another.
But I think the way I feel
about a lot of creative writing
decisions is that it's
almost like getting
dressed in the morning.
Where if I said to any of
you, "Why are you wearing
the shirt that you're wearing?"
And you'd probably say,
"Well, I put it on.
And it was fine.
So I kept it on."
Or you would say, "Well,
I put something else on,
and it felt weird.
Or I noticed it had a stain
on it, and so I changed."
So it's more like--
I mean I definitely
revise a lot.
But I think that I just go--
you have to just,
with writing, you
have to just try it
and put it down there
and see how it works.
And then, sometimes
you have to do it
that way to see how
not right it is.
But you can know how to fix it.
But I think that it is--
one of my favorite comments
about writing
fiction-- so again,
I went to graduate school.
And the director of the Iowa
Writer's Workshop at that point
was a man named Frank Conroy.
And he would say,
"Writing fiction
is this combination of
knowing what you're doing
and not knowing
what you're doing."
And I love that.
Because I do think--
I mean, it's not like--
I don't like when people
pretend like fairies
landed on my shoulder
and whispered in my ear.
But I also think there
is this weird ineffable
quality to writing fiction.
And that fiction kind of
synthesizes different elements
of life that you can't
replicate outside of fiction.
That's what fiction
has to exist.
Thank you all so
much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]